I need to add Iverbectin to my protocol to fight breast cancer in Lyme.
What dosage would you suggest I start at and then what dosage to aim for?
Should it be taken every day or a few days a week?
So the dosage for cancer and the dosage for Lyme could be very different.
The typical dosage for cancer, and I do have this on the member site, on the homepage of the member site.
It is typically the starting dosage of Iverbectin for cancer is you have to
on your computer calculate your weight in kilograms, so it's based upon your weight in kilograms.
So let's say if I weigh 200 pounds, I would have to go to just search pounds to kilogram conversion,
and you type in 200 pounds equals 90 kilograms. So that I'm always looking at my weighted
kilograms. So I weigh 90 kilograms. Starting dose for Iverbectin for cancer is typically
1.5 milligrams per kilogram per day. So if I weigh 90 kilograms that I 1.5
milligrams would be 45 milligrams per day for cancer. Typically, Iverbectin is taken daily.
Now, understand the second part of your question. Should I take it every day or a few days a week?
The typical protocol for Benbenzole starts at three days a week or four days a week,
but there's people that are taking it every day of the week, and the same thing with Iverbectin.
Typically, it's taken every day. However, there's no set perfect protocol for any of these things,
right? So there's people taking it all over the board. So there's some people doing Iverbectin
and less than that, there's some people doing it much higher. There's some people that are doing
2 milligrams per kilogram weight. So in that case, they'd be taking 180 if you weigh 200 pounds,
you'd be taking 80 kilograms a day. Well, it's a lot of Iverbectin, but if you had stage for cancer
and you had a couple of weeks to live, maybe that would be the way to jump into it. But if you're not
in that category, you may want to work up to it. So everybody's going to respond differently to it.
And so you just have to remind yourself of that. Can you have negative effects given that you have
live as well with Iverbectin? I don't know because there's just not enough data about that yet.
Could Iverbectin kill Borrelia bacteria quickly? Again, I don't know. Iverbectin is typically not used
to kill for if you place a person as lime and they go in, they never get a prescription for Iverbectin
for lime. So it's not in the category of killing bacteria. So can Iverbectin kill bacteria? I don't
know, maybe. Maybe it's going to be better aimed at killing other viral colon infections of life.
The concern that you would have if it does kill bacteria, Borrelia, burgodorphy is the bacteria
for lime, and it's a gram-negative bacteria. If you kill that too quickly, you will liberate
lipopolysaccharides, which can be very toxic to your brain, and you can get herxiber reactions.
So that's the only thing that I would be careful if you have a history of being prone to herxiber
reactions, maybe not even starting at the cancer dosage or Iverbectin and starting at a much lower
dosage like maybe 12 milligrams per day and see how you tolerate that. As always, you don't ever want
to put yourself in a crisis situation because you overdose on something that might be an overdose to you,
might not be, might be an overdose to other people, but starting slow is always the best way to go.